I loved the first four episodes like
straight up I loved them so much uh I
really can't wait for the rest of the
series man I I was really wanting to to
get to this interview because I wanted
to hear your opinion I'm so glad to hear
that the show's incredible and my
favorite part of the show is that it's
the Star Wars I've been waiting for it
has no Jedis it has no lightsabers it
has no desert planets and no Skywalkers
I I just want to explore more of the
Star Wars universe and this show is
doing that can you talk about that
aspect of the series yeah it is it is a
show about the people you know in both
sides it's quite unfair to I mean I
understand why but it's quite unfair to
call it Andor because it's pretty much
an ensemble piece you know where people
matters and story story lines are
important you know the people you'll
meet here is just regular people
surviving in very dark times of the
Galaxy in both sides in in in the Empire
uh you know in that bureaucratic system
that doesn't allow people to be people
you know uh to be themselves you know
where they're just numbers and uh and
then you have like these other people
surviving oppression uh in in very
hardcore moments you know uh and uh it's
about that need for for people to unite
to you know to to articulate a reaction
that involves Community you know it's
it's about the strength of community I
think it's it's a pretty pertinent story
also these days you know and uh
and and this long format I mean I grew
up watching film I wanted to do film
I've done film all my life but uh I tell
you one thing that the freedom that this
format this long format has brought to
us is quite unique because we can
ambition to be yes
the the action and adventure story that
Star Wars wants you to be but at the
same time very sometimes be a very
intimate journey of characters just
relating and then go to a aspireish
thriller uh political drama and come
back and transform and you know we don't
have to make choices that would alienate
us from trying other stuff new stuff and
we're allowed to be different on a way
in in the world and universe of Star
Wars and we're really pleased with that
how much would you and Tony discussed
like the full Arc of both seasons prior
to committing to making the series he he
I don't I mean he's I don't know if he
would like me to say this but I'll say
it because he was completely honest to
me and I I love that about Tony he he's
just honest and open and the best
collaborator uh
we had a phone call and he said look I'm
going to teach you what I have in mind
and I want to know your opinion before I
sit and start writing or before I commit
to this you know because we have to be
in the same page and and I I need to
know what you think and I need to know
you would like me to go there otherwise
there's no point on on sitting down and
writing these and he pitched me his
first idea you know like the full
picture
and I I just couldn't believe it you
know it was so in in tune with what I
had in mind in terms of my back story
The the one I just needed to answer to
myself in order to portray Cassian in in
Rogue one but also it was so so rich and
and and and so full of that of truthness
you know it's uh I don't know it is he
says a lot that he says like we it has
to be it has to be real but that doesn't
look real and you go like I love that
we're trying Star Wars to be real you
know but it's true we are trying and uh
we want these moments to feel like
moments you've lived of your witness or
or your friend is telling you about you
know uh and uh anyway yes we we did
connect at the very beginning and since
then we have an open conversation you
know uh we we are we are Partners in
this I I owe him everything and uh and
he's a
he knows how to work how to lead a team
he is a great leader in many ways
because he loves collaboration listen I
already got to stop I'm just going to
say man I cannot wait to watch the rest
of the series I wish you nothing but the
best and I hope we can talk again once
I've seen more let's make sure that
happens uh yeah and and man I loved it I
really I really loved it just congrats
for real thank you man